what about ai are you worried about
agi super intelligence systems or
paperclip maximizer type of type of
situation
yes i'm definitely worried about it
but i feel kind of
bipolar in the some days i wake up and
i'm like you're excited about the future
well exactly i'm like wow we can unlock
the mysteries of the universe you know
escape the game um and
this this you know if because i spend
all my time thinking about these
molecule problems that you know what
what is the solution to them
well you know in some ways you need this
like
omni benevolent omniscient omni wise
coordination mechanism that can like
make us all not do the the molecule
thing uh or like provide the
infrastructure or redesign the system so
that it's not vulnerable to this
molecule process um
and in some ways you know that's that's
the strongest argument to me for like
the race to build agi is that maybe you
know we can't survive without it
but the flip side to that
is
the
the the unfortunately now that there's
multiple actors trying to build ai agi
you know this is this was fine 10 years
ago when it was just deep mind but then
other
companies started up and now it created
a race dynamic now it's like that's the
whole thing isn't the same
it's got the same problem it's like
whichever company is the one that like
optimizes for speed at the cost of
safety will get the competitive
advantage and so we the more likely the
ones to build the agi you know and and
that's the same cycle that you're in and
there's no clear solution to that
because you can't just go like
um
slapping
you know
if you go and try and like
stop all the different companies
then
it will you know the good ones will stop
because they're the ones you know within
you know within the west's reach but
then that leaves all the other ones to
continue and then they're even more
likely so it's like it's a very
difficult problem with no clean solution
um
and
you know at the same time
you know i i
know the
at least some of the folks at deepmind
and they're incredible and they're
thinking about this they're very aware
of this problem and they're like you
know
i think some of the smartest people on
earth yeah the the culture is important
there because they are thinking about
that and they're
some of the best machine learning
engineers so it's possible to have a
company or a community of people that
are both great engineers and are
thinking about the philosophical topics
exactly and importantly they're also
game theorists
you know and because this is ultimately
a game theory problem the thing this
this monologue mechanism and like you
know what this rape how do we voice your
uh arms race scenarios um you need
people who aren't naive to be thinking
about this and again like luckily
there's a lot of smart non-naive game
theorists within within that group
yes i'm concerned about it and i i think
it's again a thing that we need
people to be thinking about um in terms
of like how do we create
how do we mitigate the arms race
dynamics and how do we
solve
the thing of it's got boston calls it
the orthogonality problem whereby
because obviously there's a chance you
know the belief the hope is is that you
build something that's super intelligent
and
by definition of being super intelligent
it will also become super wise and have
the wisdom to know what the right goals
are and hopefully those goals include
keeping humanity alive right um but
bostrom says that actually those two
things you know um super intelligence
and super wisdom
aren't necessarily correlated they're
actually kind of orthogonal things and
how do we make it so that they are
correlated how do we guarantee it
because we need it to be guaranteed
really to know that we're doing the
thing safely but i think that like
um merging of intelligence and wisdom
at least my hope is that this whole
process
happens sufficiently slowly that we're
constantly having these kinds of debates
that we have enough time to um
to figure out how to modify each version
of the system as it becomes more and
more intelligent yes buying time is is a
good thing definitely anything that
slows everything down we just
everyone needs to chill out we've got
millennia to figure this out yeah um
or at least
at least
um well it depends again it's some
people think that you know we can't even
make it through the next few decades
without having some kind of
omni-wise
coordination mechanism um and there's
also an argument to that yeah i don't
know
well there is uh i'm suspicious of that
kind of thinking because it seems like
the entirety of human history is has
people in it that are like predicting
doom
are just around the corner there's
something about us
that
is strangely attracted to that thought
it's it's almost like fun to think about
the destruction of everything
just objectively speaking
i've
talked and listened to a bunch of people
and they are
gravitating towards that it's almost
i think it's the same thing that people
love about conspiracy theories
is they love to be the person that kind
of figured out
some deep
fundamental thing about the that's going
to be it's going to mark something
extremely important about the history of
human civilization because then
i will be important right when in
reality most of us will be forgotten and
and and
life will will go on i mean one of the
sad things about
whenever anything traumatic happens to
you whenever you lose loved ones
or
just tragedy happens you realize life
goes on
even after a nuclear war that will wipe
out
some large percentage of the population
and will torture
people for
years to come because of the sort of i
mean the effects of a nuclear winter
people will still survive
life will still go on i mean it depends
on the kind of nuclear war but in in
case in nuclear world it will still go
on that's one of the amazing things
about life it finds a way and so in that
sense i just i feel like the doom and
gloom thing
is uh
but what we don't yeah we don't want a
self-fulfilling prophecy yes that's
exactly yes and i very much agree with
that and i you know even i have a slight
like feeling from the amount of time we
spent in this conversation talking about
this because it's like
you know is this even a net positive if
it's like making everyone feel oh
in some ways like making people imagine
these bad scenarios can be a
self-fulfilling prophecy but at the same
time
that's how
that's weighed off with at least making
people aware of the problem
and gets them thinking and i think
particularly you know the reason why i
want to talk about this to your audience
is that
on average they're the type of people
who gravitate towards these kind of
topics because they they're
intellectually curious and
and they can sort of sense that there's
trouble brewing yeah they can smell that
there's you know i think there's a
reason people are thinking about this
stuff a lot is because
the probability
the probability you know it's increased
in probability over certainly over the
last few years
um trajectories have not gone favorably
let's put it in you know since 2010. so
um it's right i think for people to be
thinking about it but that's where
they're like i think whether it's a
useful fiction or whether it's actually
true or whatever you want to call it i
think having this faith this is where
faith is valuable
because it gives you at least this like
anchor of hope
and and i and i'm not just saying it to
like trick myself like i do truly i do
think there's something out there that
wants us to win yeah i think there's
something that really wants us to win
and it just you just have to be like
just like
okay now i sound really crazy but like
open your heart to it a little bit yeah
and
it will give you the like
the sort of breathing room with which to
marinate on the solutions we are the
ones who have to come up with solutions
but
we
can use that there's like there's
hashtag positivity there's value in that
yeah you have to kind of imagine all the
destructive trajectories that lay in our
future and then believe
in the possibility of avoiding those
trajectories all while you said
audience all while sitting back which is
majority the two people that listen to
this are probably sitting on a beach
smoking some weed
um just
that's a beautiful sunset or they're
looking at just the waves going in and
out
and ultimately there's a kind of deep
belief there and um
the the momentum of humanity to figure
it all out i think we'll make it
but we've got a lot of work to do which
is which what makes this whole
simulation this video game kind of fun
this uh battle of politopia
i still man i love those games so much
so good and then that that one for
people who don't know but uh battle
polytopia is a is a big it's like a
really radical
simplification of a civilization type of
game it still has a lot of the skill
tree development a lot of the strategy
but it's easy enough to play in a phone
yeah it's kind of interesting they've
really
they've really figured it out it's it's
one of the most elegantly designed games
i've ever seen it's incredibly complex
and yet being again it walks that line
between complexity and simplicity in
this really really great way um
and they use pretty colors that
hack the dopamine reward circuits in our
brains very well yeah it's fun
video games are so fun yeah
most of this life is just about fun
escaping all the suffering to find the
fun
you